thanks for joining us America in the
lobby of Ramsey solutions Austin and
Kayla are here hey guys how are ya
very good how are you Dave welcome
welcome I'm guessing you're here to do a
debt-free scream yes we are where do you
live we live in Richmond Kentucky oh
cool not too bad I Drive down to
Nashville well especially on a pretty
day like this yeah thanks for hanging
out with us how much dead of your paid
off we paid our $15,000 awesome and how
long did that take you 11 months good
job making what kind of money $36,000 a
year awesome
how many kids you got we have two sons
and their ages are named Aaron is three
years old almost four and Adam is 18 18
months that's classic and you guys are
how old I am 26 and she is not I love it
good very good what do you guys do for a
living my wife is a stay-at-home mom I
am a pizza delivery driver full-time
making thirty six thousand bucks yes
very cool good for you
love it so uh tell me your story what
happened eleven months ago that made you
decide to get rid of the debt the story
actually starts a long time before that
six years ago when I was a sophomore in
college my wife was going through
college debt-free and I won FPU in a
Christmas giveaway at first I had no
idea what it was but when I went through
it I decided to go take on no new debt
for my college degree and from that year
for the fall of 2010 to just a year ago
I paid we paid $60,000 for my aviation
degree cash float on a delivery pizza
income Wow
plus having two kids in that time as
well so then after that was done we were
able to attack the student loans last
year and are able to pay it off huh very
cool so student loans are kind of
bumping along on hold till you finish
the aviation yeah and then you step on
them yes and he will tell you that that
was the hardest part for him was just
waiting like oh this this debt is just
waiting for me to pay it off and I'm
listening to Dave all the time and I'm
supposed to be paying it off but I got
to get through college first
so you you've got a four year degree in
aviation yes cool and what are you gonna
do fly planes oh I was guessing anything
in particular any any good leads right
now I have a lead in a missionary group
but nothing right now I'm just waiting
very cool good well congratulations you
guys
so 11 months you pay off 15,000 making
36 with two babies at home you've been
eating the pizza that didn't get
delivered it's legal that's why you're
allowed to do that they let you have it
cuz I got to throw it out anyway right
yes yeah so that's fun I mean you guys
have been living on nothing you really
have
that's an amazing set of numbers right
there I mean you you really I mean Kayla
you must be like the world's best home
economist well I will say that when when
we were going through college debt-free
like I was already at that point I
looked at ohm and I'm spending a
thousand dollars a semester for a meal
plan well I can make it in the college
basement and in my dorm basement I can
go make it for a week and then eat on
that and then on the next weekend I'll
start that so like I had already started
that process before we got married and
got into couponing when couponing was
big and and so now it's just been a
matter of like fine-tuning it okay well
I don't have time to coupon with two
little ones running around the way that
I did then but I still know that we can
make it with what we have yeah like I've
watched God provide faithfully so I know
that even if this month's tight it's not
gonna always be this way yeah way to go
wow you guys are impressive you pull
this off your eyes you have sacrificed
to do two things and wanted to get out
of debt and of course the second to
finish though the aviation degree you
know you know how to pay a price to win
you will always be winning you really
will congratulations how does it feel
surreal a little bit because I get paid
on a weekly basis and so the month
hasn't actually come to where the money
goes out and so it'll be nice when the
money doesn't go out anymore
yeah that'll be very cool well
congratulations you're very very proud
of you all right
it's Austin and Kayla Erin and Adam from
Lexington Kentucky area Richmond
Kentucky fifteen thousand dollars in
student loan debt paid off in 11 months
making thirty six thousand dollars as a
pizza delivery driver count it down
let's hear a great debt free scream
three two one guys aren't really sure
why they're getting clapped for I love
it very cool man hi I tell you I hear
people all the time say well you know do
those people calling you know doing the
debt free scream gentle make $80,000
don't make it they make thirty six
thousand dollars as a pizza delivery
driver she stays at home with two little
babies and they paid off $15,000 in debt
in 11 months so you know some of you
thought I was a little bit tough on that
lady they called earlier and I wasn't
being tough on her I was being tough on
her situation because her numbers just
weren't acceptable in 15 months she paid
off two thousand dollars making one
hundred and one thousand in eleven
months they paid off $15,000 $15,000 not
two thousand dollars making only thirty
six thousand dollars you see this is
this is my life this is what I walk in
every day these numbers and so those
guys like they were just on here our
heroes they're the ones that find a way
to win they find a way to win and it's
tough it's hard but it's worth it
because now they don't have a payment in
the world not only did they not finance
his aviation degree but they also have
learned to live on I mean nothing
nothing they paid off fifteen thousand
dollars out of thirty six and eleven
months you do that math they're living
on nothing they
they can do that they can do anything
there's an it's nowhere the sky's the
limit they're going nowhere but up from
here and only 26 years old already there
already got control of their budget
something Congress can't do hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and say
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind